[Music]
looking live there on Capitol Hill we
have very special guests to bring in
Daniel Krauthammer he is the son of
longtime syndicated columnist and Fox
News contributor Charles Krauthammer he
is a friend as his father was and he has
compiled a book of his late father's
work finished and completed his late
father's work books called the point of
it all
a lifetime of great loves and endeavors
which comes out tomorrow and Daniel
thank you for doing this thank you for
having me on fact that you chose special
rapport in this very chair to be the
first interview is important to us it's
important to me it's it's the right
place to do it the only place to do it I
think how did this come to be
so my father was working on a second
collection a follow-up to his 2013 book
things that matter and he was a long way
into the process when his health crisis
struck a little over a year and ago now
I guess 16 months ago now and he was
able to continue working on it
a little bit during his hospitalization
which I helped him with and we kind of
jerry-rigged as his room to help him use
the computer and be able to look at this
and continue compiling it but when the
final diagnosis came he entrusted me to
finish it for him and so since he passed
in June that's been my absolute number
one priority and what was it that he
said to you about compiling this book
and I should point out you do the
foreword and also a beautiful ending
which actually is the eulogy you
delivered at his funeral yeah I had a
sense of where he wanted to go with it
he had already chosen most of what's in
the book now there was still quite a bit
to be added and and to be arranged and
make sure that it all really fit
together and that the core ideas spoke
through which wasn't too hard because
his thinking and his clarity were so
apparent and they
coming out from reading the book front
to back but I I finished that put it
together and as you said I wrote an
introduction to explain how I thought it
all came together in conjunction with
his politics his personality his
philosophy and his fun passions and the
humor and as you say the last entry in
the book is the eulogy I delivered at
his funeral which was a difficult
decision to put that in because it's
obviously very personal and close to my
heart but I I wanted to the world to
know how wonderful he was and how
extraordinary he was and that was the
best way I knew how
and I interviewed him many times for the
hour that we did in subsequent hours and
I tried to get him to talk about you and
your mom Robin and he was always a
little hesitant to do that a lot
hesitant I should say this book has a
lot more personal information that I had
ever heard Charles talk about yeah and
that was that wasn't an easy decision
either because as you say he was very
private especially about me and my
mother and I think I love him for that
and he was protecting us and not wanting
to make us part of his profession his
career and I thought long and deep about
how much and how personal to get in this
book but as I wrote an introduction now
that he is gone it's different and I I
think there's a power to his voice his
first person voice speaking as himself
and not just his political arguments
that so many people have reached out to
me and spoken to me about in the months
since and I realized how much he really
touched a lot of people's lives and I I
wanted the world to be able to see that
and read that and I I think he would
approve I'm sure he would we miss his
voice every night on this panel I can't
tell you how many emails and tweets and
messages I gets and I wonder what
Charles would think about
this I really miss his voice you know
today with the remembrance of the 41st
president found this picture with your
dad and your mom with President George
HW Bush and a reflection of a column
looking back after he loses in 1992 in
which he says quote bushes was not a
failed presidency but a completed one
history called him to do two things to
close out the Cold War and thwart the
ambitions of a reckless tyrant in the
Persian Gulf Bush did both rather well
Bush was born and trained for these two
jobs but only these two by the end of
four years there was nothing left for
him to do it is also the reason his
country turned him out of office the
voters judgment however is not to be
confused with history's it may suit
partisan journalism to equate losing
with failure but history does not follow
the polls what's amazing about Charles
is he could always cut through the noise
now looking back everyone is saying this
saying this moment this presidency was
larger than the 38% he received in that
election but he said it back in 1992 I
know I had the same feeling actually I
was looking back at his old columns when
I heard the news about former President
Bush and I was struck by this too that I
looked at the Dateline and as with
actually so many pieces of his writing
that are in his book and other places it
feels like it could be written today and
I remember you were talking about just
earlier on the show but the mention of
Churchill and Truman which are my dad
also mentioned in this article that you
know he had a very deep sense of history
which comes through in his writing and
his sense that some of the greatest
leaders are they accomplished what they
need to for history and then their turn
is over and it was a very poetic
appreciation of history I thought
there's amazing things in this book
about foreign policy about domestic
policy longer kind of than his columns
even their speeches stuff that nuggets
that you really wouldn't even see in
writings ya know there's quite a few
pieces in this book that haven't been
seen or published anywhere before as you
say some speeches one completely new
original long essay about the rise of
authoritarianism and populism that he
wrote in July 2017 that hadn't been
published and some long ruminations on
the big ideas of what's America's role
in the world what are the ideological
challenges to democracy in the 21st
century along with fun stuff like
baseball and chess and all the rest of
it he was such an interesting character
but I know most people saying looking at
this interview will say just ask what
was it like having Charles as your dad
wonderful
I think asked about his limitations and
obviously he had limitations but to you
you didn't see him no I think you know
you know what you know when you grow up
and I think he faced difficulties in his
life and everyone faces difficulties in
their life and he lives such a full and
vibrant life in the life he wanted and
he made it the life that he wanted for
me too
and I never felt wanting for anything
and in fact as I've gotten older I've
only been able to look back and realize
just how lucky I was and especially now
I think about that all the time well we
were lucky to have him
for the years that we did especially
here on special report this book I am
honored to give a blurb on the back it
says this there are people who might
meet you meet throughout your life that
you just know will leave an impact
forever Charles Krauthammer was one of
those people his words and his knowledge
and his eloquence on the issues of the
day were unsurpassed he could cut
through the noise he could get to the
point better than anybody it's a real
honor I'm gonna sell a hundred these 100
million of these books if I can
thank you very much thank you breath
good luck thank